a bordo del ratón y que navega con
bandera de sierra leona más de 26.000
toneladas de maíz ucraniano un miembro
de la tripulación compartió su alegría
por haber zarpado tras meses de estar
atrapado en el puerto bajo la constante
amenaza de bombardeos
fue una sensación increíble me sentí
como si fuéramos libres después de haber
estado detenidos durante mucho tiempo no
me ayudan para track btr y el embarque
fue posible gracias al acuerdo alcanzado
el mes pasado entre ucrania y rusia con
la intermediación de turquía y las
naciones unidas- el pacto pretende
permitir el paso seguro de los barcos de
cereales y fertilizantes desde los
puertos de odessa el buque llegará
primero a estambul para su inspección
antes de dirigirse a trípoli en líbano
el día del alivio para el mundo tuiteó
el ministro de asuntos exteriores
ucraniano mientras quien celebraba el
acontecimiento como un paso para evitar
el hambre en el mundo
ucrania es un importante productor de
cereales con un 10 por ciento del
mercado mundial de trigo y un 15 por
ciento del
pero la guerra ha impedido que sus
barcos salgan de los puertos lo que ha
provocado un aumento de los precios
mundiales de los alimentos se espera que
más barcos zarpen en los próximos días
según funcionarios presidenciales
ucranianos 17 navíos están atracados en
los puertos del mar negro con casi
600.000 toneladas de carga el desbloqueo
de los puertos también proporcionaría a
ucrania el dinero que tanto necesita ya
que los ataques rusos continúan incluso
en granjas y silos